ですから全然役に立ってないんです
人間の幸せのためには
全く役に立ってないんです
そんなもんで 心の安らぎ
人間の平和 人間の幸せ
幸福のために何も貢献してないんです
ですから ここでお釈迦様が推薦するのは
ちょっとそれを置いておいて
それも全く科学的な見方なんです
体を中身を見なさいと
そこに心臓がある 骨がある
血液がある それからまたいろいろありますね
まあとにかく三十二に分けてますけどね
骨と骨髄とわっかん腎臓ただやん心臓
それからキローマカンっていうのは
どこかから調べれば日本の言葉で出てくるかもしれません
覚えてないんだけど とにかくまあ
腎臓 心臓 肺 腸 それから胃の中のもの
それから大便 小便 それから胆汁
唾液 そういうふうに分けてるんですね
流れるもの 硬いもの 中間的な筋肉とかね
それはもうそうやってチースイカー風に一応分かれるような感じで
三十二にして そうやって分解してみなさいと
そうやって分解すると
私が偉いんだという気持ちが消えちゃうんですね
私の心臓も他の人の心臓も心臓であって
本当は見たら気持ち悪いものなんですね
腸はもう客観的に見たらそんなありがたいものじゃないんです
で 気持ち悪くなるからみんな反対しますけどね
そこはもう意味がないんです
動物の腸とか食べてるんだけどね
じゃあ犬の腸食べますか？牛の腸は食べてるんだけど
だからもう屁理屈は世の中にあるもんであってね
魚の胃袋も胃袋の中に入ってる
ものすごい汚いものを食べてるでしょ
特に 魚っていうのはろくなもの食べてないしね
汚いものばっかり食べてるし
魚小さい魚の場合はそのまんま食べてるでしょうし
大きい動物になってくると
それは汚いんだ 捨てましょうとか偉そうなこと言ったりするし
だからそちらにあるのは人間の綺麗な屁理屈だけなんですね
そこをうまく使って客観的に見なさいと
そうするとなんとなく気持ち悪いものやとなるんですね
自分の体もそういうものだと
それでも煩悩が消えてしまうんですね
欲がなくなっちゃうんですね
高慢が消えちゃうんですね
そこで高慢が消えたら
他人とは怒らないし 嫉妬もしないし
すごく落ち着いている人間になるんです
そのためにそのカーエガターサティ
カーエというのは体 ガターというのは体についての念じること
このアヌッサティのアヌの代わりにカーエガターと言うんですね
このカーエガターというのは
ガターという言葉はアヌという言葉同じ意味で使っているんです
この十種類の中で インドの世界では瞑想と言っている世界で
瞑想らしき瞑想はアーナパーナサティなんですね
でもそれもあまりすごい意味で取ってはいけません
この瞑想みたいなものは
仏教では結局はそんなに大事な意味で考えてるわけじゃないんです
瞑想よりは智慧の方がよろしいと
瞑想して何か超能力を得てね
堕落するよりは智慧が発達して人格が素晴らしい人格が生まれていければ
それであなたは幸福ですよと
必要なのは幸福な心 幸せな心
平安な心でしょうし 威張る心ではないんですね
それでまあそうやって瞑想たくさんあって
最後にこのアーナパーナサティという呼吸瞑想ですね
で 呼吸瞑想の場合はもうこれはちゃんとしたこの瞑想ですね
それでもっていろんなサマーディ状態
サマーディ状態はすべて生まれてくるんです
このブッダの教えなどなどからサマーディは生まれません
これはあの このチャートにあると思います
この種類の随念で このチャートにあるように見ると
このなんかカヤガタサティはパタマッジャーナ生まれるんだと書いてますけどね
でもアーナパーナサティからは全部ジャーナ禅定が生まれてくるんです
カヤガタサティから本当にジャーナが生まれるかどうかね
わかりませんね 私は 書いてるんだからあるあるでしょうというぐらいは
私の個人的な意見で言うならば
このアーナパーナサティだけなんですけどね
でもテキストに逆らうこともできませんし
じゃあアーナパーナサティって何でしょうか？と
それはこの呼吸ですね
呼吸によって呼吸に従って呼吸と一緒に自分の念という感じることをずっと持っていくという意味なんですね
だから すべての雑念をやめて
考えることもやめて 他の体のことも
世の中のこともすべてやめて
自分のこの思考能力 感じる能力を呼吸だけに縛っておく
基本的にはそういう働きなんですね
何も考えてはいけません
体のことは全く考えてはいけません
外のことを全く考えてはいけません
ですから これは座ってやらないと
座ってじっとこう 呼吸だけ
呼吸の動きだけ見ているんですね
そこでブッダゴサ長老がこの鼻の先に集中して
そこで出入りする空気の出入りのところで観察しなさいと
この鼻の先の先っぽのところで
そこで空気と体が触れるところなんですね
初めて で そこで観察すると
すごく早いんです 瞑想は
なぜならば もう体の中のことを考えてないんですから
で そこは瞑想をどのように進めるかということは
このアーナパーナ・スッタという経典があります
で その経典にいくらかステージを書いているんです
あってもやっぱりこの経典では全部ヴィパッサナーに行くようにもうつなげているんです
サマーディが生まれるようにというよりは
サマーディがついでに生まれるんだったら
まあもうそれはそれで
生まれても生まれなくても
やっぱりヴィパッサナーの智慧の方に進むように経典では書いているんです
まあサマーディっていうのはそんなに説明は難しくはないんだけど
やっぱりこの一つだけ見ていると他のもの見えてこないと
人間というのはものすごくすっごい興味が生まれてきて
この集中力っていうのはものすごい興味ということなんですね
楽しくなっちゃうんですね
この楽しみっていうのはものすごいおかしいことで
ものがあってもなくても楽しい人は楽しいでしょうし
例えば脳の中でこの電察働きですか
シナプスの働きがすごく働いている場合は
いわゆる神経回路いっぱいできている人はいつでも明るいんです
何かあってもなくても常に楽しいんですね
これまあドパミンの問題ですけどね
で だからこの 快感物質ですか
で そういうものをいっぱい脳を作っちゃうし
その脳がこの快感物質作るんだったら
別になんのことなくても楽しめるんですね
何か音楽聴かなくちゃとかね
何て言いますか 何か映画館にでもあるいはどこか行かなくちゃとかね
そこまでやらなくても楽しいんです
例えばこのうつ的な暗い人々は
たとえ外国に連れて行ったって文句ばっかし言って帰るでしょうし
楽しみは味わえないんですね
だからそこはもう本当に無駄遣いですよ
楽しみを探していくのは無駄遣いなんです
一番早い方法っていうのは
楽しみを味わう自分の頭を直すことなんですね
で どうしても脳細胞っていうのは
まあ歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
もうピチンと止まっちゃいますからね
まあそこはもう締め切りだそうですね
残念ですけど 能力も全て
ですから まあ瞑想でもするしか方法ないんですね
瞑想でもすると またそれはすごい強引な運動だから
すごい強引な知識運動なんです
そこでもし神経回路をいろいろできて作ってくるならば
まあかなり気絶感というのは感じてくるんですね
まあそれと伴って能力も当然ながらいろんな能力もつく場合もあるし
つかない場合もありますけど
とにかく興味というものは必要なんですね
人間の我々の場合も 我々の差がこの興味によってあるでしょうに
音楽に興味ある人は音楽家にミュージシャンになっちゃうし
絵に興味ある人は画家になるし
そうやって自分がどこで快感感じるかっていうことなんです
絵を描いて全然快感感じない人は
もう画家にはならないんですね
数学を計算することですごく快感感じる人は
まあ数学者になってしまったり
そのようにこのやっぱりこの
刺激ですか 脳細胞の刺激ですけどね
そこは自分が人がこの快感感じる方向へ進んでしまっちゃうんです
まあそこら辺は私の管轄分野ではないんですけどね
まあ言ってることは間違ってる可能性もあるかもしれませんし
まあそれはまあ他の医学系やらね
脳の研究する人々の世界ですからね
とにかくこの年取ってしまっても
この脳のこの強引な運動やるとやっぱりなんとかまた新しい神経回路が生まれてくる可能性あります
例えば たとえ年取っていても
それなりの運動をするとそれなりに体力つくでしょうに
まるっきり不可能ということじゃないんだからね
例えば体の場合はね まあ若い子供みたいにみんなに運動できませんだけど
まあ体壊れないぐらい計算しながらちゃんと科学的に運動し続けると
人はまあいくら年取ってもそれなりに体がちゃんと自由自在に動かすことはできる
ですから体もそこまで可能ですから
脳細胞も当然なことでも育てれば育てられます
まあ若い人ほど早くないかもしれませんだけどね
瞑想にしても やっぱりもう若いうちに
やるんだったらもうすごいんですよ
力は それでアナパニサティっていう場合は
この 早くも一つのものに集中する
いきなりそこから始まるんです
鼻の先に触れる空気を感じるということから始まるんですね
そこで吸ってます 吐いてますとか
なんとか言葉で確認しながら
それでどんどんどんどんそれだけ見えてくる
初めは体も感じますけどね
体も座ってることも 音もいろんなこと感じますけど
それはもう見ようと聞こうとしない
雑念が生まれたらすぐそれやめて
やっぱり吸ってます 吐いてますと
結構難しいんだけど 空気と一緒に意識を持っていく
中へ持っていって 外へ持っていく
それだけやってるとどんどんそれだけ見えるようになる
そこら辺は経典では全身を持って吸ってます
吐いてますと書いてますね
そこでその人にとっては全身
体全体は呼吸だけになるんですね
そこで主観的 客観的という主観的
客観的というか そうですかな
何かというと見方で 変えてみるんですね
まあ内から呼吸を見るか
外から呼吸を見るかという
そのどちらの訓練もするんですね
それによってさらに集中力が生まれてくるんです
見る人が内に入れて吸ってます
吐いてますと 見る働きが外に入れて
別に具体的に不可能ですけど
この見方ですね で 外から吸ったり吐いたり吸ったりするんですね
そこだと思いますけど
これはこのあまり注釈書でもあまり理解
そんな説明ではないんですね
この内アッジャッタヴァーカーイというふうにあって
アサシッサスッヤティ
バヒッダーヴァーカーイという風に
アッジャッタっていうのは自分
内なる体 バヒッダーカーイというのは外なる体という解釈しますけど
うちの体 外の体は何でしょうかという問題が出てくると
時々瞑想してない人かどうか分かりません
時々人々はこう言うんですね
自分の呼吸と他人の呼吸も観察するんだと
どうやって観察できるんです？私は分かりませんだけど
人の呼吸は あの伝統的な教育のない人は平気でそんなことを言うんです
だから私たちすごい神経質なんですね
瞑想をなめた人々が説明すると
仏陀様さえはっきり説明してないんだからと
あの偉大なる方にもそこら辺はどうかなと
分からなかったかもしれませんし
分かったかもしれませんし
どっちか分かりませんだけど
私が ですから これはあくまでも私個人の意見として聞かせていただいても構いませんし
とにかく瞑想するのは自分ですから
この見方の立場ではないかと
内から呼吸を見ていて
外から呼吸を見ると ですから
例えば何かあの ここら辺
何か触れちゃって怪我して痛いんだと
内から痛み感じることもできるし
ここら辺でここら辺に痛いんだと
自分と関係ないような感じで外から感じる痛み感じることもできるでしょうに
ですから 別に痛みは動いているわけでも何でもないんです
これはちょっとしたことで感じますよ
例えば頭が痛い場合は
本当に頭が痛くてどうしようもないという場合は
この内から見ているんですね
まあここら辺も頭がここら辺すごく痛いんですよという
こうやって外から見ることも感じることもできますね
痛みはそのままですけどね
ですから 内から見る 外から見るという
その方法で すごくこの集中能力がどんどん増してくる
それで内も外ももうやめて
ただそのものだけ見ているということに行く
それお釈迦様アッジャッタバヒッダー
内の体と外の体とまとめて見るんだということで
もうちょっと観察能力が優れたっていうことですね
それから次にサマーディが生まれてくるんです
だからサマーディっていうのは
まあなんかちょっとした心の変化みたいなもんで
まああれまあ言えばなんか不思議な体験みたいなもんで
もうなかなか言いにくいんだけどね
いわゆるまあ現代的な考える方々に
私はよく自分消えちゃうような感じなんですね
自分消えちゃったんだけど
しっかりとそこにこの瞑想というか
その働きだけ自動的にさっと続けてしまうと
で それ後でなんですね
気がつくのは そういうこともあったんですと
後でというのはすぐすぐその場ですけど
なんか自動的に瞑想行ってしまったような感じで
自動的に行っちゃったんだから
自分が自分がいてやるということは
やっぱり二次元的なんですね
例えば我々 今自分が見ている
自分が聞いてるんだからね
だから主体客体の差があるんですね
サマーディの瞬間では
主体客体の差がなくなっちゃうんですね
現象のみあると 呼吸という
呼吸現象がやっぱり観察する心と呼吸という物質的な働き
二つとなければ成り立たないんですね
空気が動くことに呼吸と言えませんだから
空気が体に触れることにも呼吸と言えませんよ
火星でも体に触れますけど
それには呼吸してるんだとは言えません
ですから 呼吸という働きが
吸う吐くという働きが
やっぱりこの生命体というのは命でしょうし
心でしょうし その心が空気と持っている関係なんですね
ですから それだけになると現象だけ
主体客体 客体状態が消えちゃって
それはサマーディなんですね
ですから サマーディ体験した人は
それはしっかりとわかってるんですね
こういうことだと それはこの自動的に生まれるまで頑張らなくちゃいけない
自分で作ることはできないんです
だから 単なる呼吸の瞑想を続けるしか方法ないんです
とにかく呼吸瞑想をじっと続けて続けてやらなくちゃいけない
それでまあ条件揃ったらサマーディが生まれていきます
それでサマーディのいろいろつありますから
それは集中力のレベルの問題なんですね
だから より強い集中力で一体感が生まれたら
第二番目のサマーディで
もっとすごい力強く一体感が生まれたら第三番目で
それから第五番目と そこでこのサマーディの差
解説 説明しているのは
この集中力のレベルだから
最初は言葉でもって瞑想して
やっと集中力生まれる
言葉なしにはできません
すごく快楽 快感 喜悦感も感じる
楽しみも感じる ものすごく
で 二番目っていうのは
言葉の助けなくてもさっとサマーディに入られると
言葉の助けなくても その統一状態が生まれるということは
かなりレベル高い集中力がそこに働いています
それは二番目のサマーディで
三番目のサマーディっていうのは
この激しいドーパミンの働きなくても統一することはできるんですね
四番目っていうのは このその喜悦感もないと
それでもできるんだと
普通の人っていうのは
やっぱり何て言いますか
快感ないとやらないんです
これは全ての生命はそういうことが楽しくなきゃ何もやりません
[笑い]だから大物でないとこんな楽しみだからやるとかどことではなくてできるということはね
だからこの番目のサマーディ
一番高いレベルのサマーディ色界に
その場合は気絶感 気絶感もないんです
あるのはウペッカーだけ
まあそれでサマーディのレベルがあって
呼吸瞑想でそれ全部サマーディ作られます
そこでアーナパナサティの瞑想から我々得るところは
そうやって第一禅定 二
三 三 四禅定を作ること
前の瞑想で禅定を作ることではなくて
違う目的それぞれあるんです
それからあの 二十七八の九番目アッパマンニャーという瞑想
四つですね 無量 無量瞑想っていうのは四つがあります
それはメッター カルナ
ムディター ウペッカーという瞑想なんですね
で メッター カルナ ムディター
ウペッカーの瞑想は必ずしも生命に対する自分の態度なんですね
だから私たちは他の生命に対してどのどんな態度を取ればよろしいかと
そこで一番正しい態度っていうのはメッター
カルナ ムディター ウペッカーと四つなんですね
だからその瞑想のやり方はまたいろいろいろいろあります
で アビダンマではそこら辺説明しませんだけど
まあ初期アビダンマではね
ただ四つを覚えておきなさいと
まあそれだけなんですけど
で まあメッターはいつでも一つの瞑想っていうのは
この四つの自分にとってはすごく分かりやすい
自分には納得いける 集中できる
一つ選ぶ その四つの中で簡単に理解できる一つ選んで
そこはずっと実践してみること
だからメッターっていうのは友情ですから
まあ軽々くできるんですね
で 全ての生命に対して
まあはっきり言えば仲間だと思うことなんですね
みんなまあ同じ仲間ですよ
普通の人間の場合はその気持ちは一般的にはあります
でも人間が仲間というのはほんのちょっとの何人かなんですね
すごい数が限ってるんですね
一人 二人 三人 四人とかね
そこはもう全然瞑想でも何でもないんですけどね
そちらにあるのはやっぱり差別するために
区別するための仲間意識なんですね
仲間と仲間でない状態と
ですから仲間意識があっても
それは慈悲ということにはならないんです
メッターということにはならないんですね
仲間意識 グループ意識作って
他人をもう排除して追い出してるんだから
あんた方は関係ないんだ
そこで仏教の答えはやっぱりこういう排除する気持ちではなくて
どんどんどんどん受け入れなさいと
自分の仲間というこのサークルをどんどんどんどんどんどん増やしなさいと
だから論理的にやってますから
ちゃんとした理屈に基づいてやってるんだから
私はもう幸せでいたいし
私の仲間も親しい人々も幸せでいたいということでサークルを大きくするんですね
それでなんで私とその人々だけやと
他の人々も幸せになってほしいと
それでどんどん増えて
すべての生命が幸せになってほしい
仲間ではないと それで無量っていうのは
まあそれで限りないという制限決めませんと
リミットは決めませんと
アンリミテッドということで無制限に
だから条件一つ生命であるならば
私は慈しみの気持ちを実践しますと
だから 自分の慈しみの気持ちを実践するために必要するのは条件たった一つ
相手が生命かないか ただそれだけ
相手が石だったら別に慈悲をしなくてもいいんです
だから 本当に厳密に理解してほしいんです
アビダンマというのは単なる頭の運動じゃなくて
これは仏教の教えだから
性格が変わらないと全然勉強したことにならないんですね
勉強したことになるために
いわゆる勉強としたければね
そんな遊びでまたできないので
ものすごい力が必要なんで
これすごい難しいんだからね
ですから 私はアビダンマのこの難しいところは全然感じないようにして
アビダンマのこの人間らしいところはずっと強調してずっと話してきましたからね
だから学問的なところは恐ろしいんです
理解できないわけないんだけど
学問だからね でもすごく時間とすごく勉強しなくちゃ
覚えておかなくちゃいけない
いろいろ書いたり あっちこっちいろいろやらなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで性格が直るわけないんですね
ですから この慈悲というは慈しみっていうのは自分が本当にやっているかないかと
この形だけの慈悲と お釈迦様が考えた慈悲と
格好だけの慈悲 威張るための慈悲
他人と区別するための慈悲
あんた知ってますか？私は慈悲の瞑想をやっているんだと
言いたがるんだったら
それは差別感覚でしょう
あんたはやってない 私はやってるんだと
どうだいと  [笑い]それは慈悲じゃないんですね
ごく普通の世の中でやってる自慢話と全く同じ
自分の心に本当にどんな人をでも受け入れられますかと
そこは慈悲のチェックポイントなんですね
自分の心の中に仲間としてどんな人も受け入れられますかと
だから まあ何と言いますか
具体的にいいんで 最初はまあ自分の仲間ですね
仲間は全く平等に受け入れられますかと
それからどんどん数を増やしてみる
それから他の生命も入れてみる
それからすべての生命
生命であるならば 私はもう仲間に入れているんだと
というふうな瞑想ですから
だから慈悲を実践している人であるならば
全然怒りとか憎しみとか
相手を非難したくなる気持ちとかに
貶したくなる気持ちとか
相手に負けませんとかに
ああだこうだとかね 生命に対するそういうもう苦しみというかね
まあ嫌な感覚は消えていくはずなんですね
そうやって自分にとってはこの仲間意識育てる
そこは無料に行く 無制限に持っていく
無制限と分からないんだったら
仏教で簡単に東西南北上下と
そこはもう無限に 簡単でしょ
理解するのは 東西南北もあまり言ってないけど
前と後と右と左と上と下と
そちらどこまで行ったっても
もうキリがないでしょうに
そこら辺にいるすべての生命が
生命であるならばもう仲間ですよと
幸せでいてほしいと 楽しげてほしいと
だから慈悲経でははっきりと人を人ではなく
生命は生命を貶すなかれと
貶すって自分が偉くて
あんた方はなんでそういうふうに思うのかと
嫉妬 憎しみ 苦しみはあってほしくないんだと
ナパルーパラニクッテト
人というよりは 生命が生命を侮辱しないように
貶さないように それから怒りの気持ち
憎しみの気持ち ビヤールーサナパティヴェサンニャー
ナーニャマンニャッス
誰にもないようにと どの人々の間でも
自分と他人の間でも どちらでもないようにと
ナーニャマンニャッスドゥッカミッチェイヤ
互いに苦しみを望まないこと
生命がどんな生命でも
お互いに苦しみ 苦しみというのは人を苦しめることだからね
そういう気持ちがならないようにと
すごい美しい文章なんですね
慈悲経で言えるのは 譬えまで出てきて
一人の子を守る母のごとく
すべての生命をお互いにそれぐらいお互いに心配してほしいんだと
他の生命に対して だからそういう気持ちは慈悲の瞑想で
それで自分瞑想する場合は
もし自分の心は心の大きさですか
それはどんどん大きくなって
やがて自分も他人も本当に同じということにも
もうしっかりと自分がもうそうなってしまうんですね
区別して考えることさえも不可能になるんですね
そこで瞑想としてやっていると
また同じくこのそういう気持ちになって
なんか一体感みたいになってしまう
それを第一禅定で そうやって第四禅定までできます
これは友情という仲間ということ
それできない場合は ある人にとってはメッターよりはカルマやりやすいかも
カルマの場合は これは簡単に助けたいという気持ちなんですね
何とかしてあげたいと
何とか助けたいと ですから
慈悲よりは慈しみよりは難しい